die usa sorgen mit ihrer neuen
nuklearstrategie für verunsicherung
russland verkündet mit seinen modernsten
raketen jeden abwehrschirm überwinden zu
können und in syrien wird der
bürgerkrieg immer mehr zu einem
stellvertreterkrieg in dem auch die usa
und russland eine starke rolle spielen
das forschungsinstitut sie briefe könnte
zeitgleich das weltweit die
rüstungsausgaben steigen heute in
frecher kompakt kehrt der kalte krieg
zurück angesichts dieser entwicklungen
ist es nicht verwunderlich dass die
münchner sicherheitskonferenz 2018 unter
dem titel bis zum abgrund und zurück
sagte viele analytiker wie auch besorgt
der menschen fragen sich ob er einen
neuen kalten krieg entgegensteuern
dazu vielleicht fünf merkmale die diese
zeit von 1949 bis 1990 die phase die als
kalter krieg bezeichnet wird prägten
punkt eins eine ideologische konkurrenz
kommunismus versus kapitalismus und
liberale system eine bipolare welt
ordnung wo hier die zwei machtblöcke
washington für den westen und moskau für
den osten versuchten möglichst viele
länder und staaten auf ihre seite zu
ziehen möglichst viele verbündete zu
finden militärischen niederschlag fand
das in der gründung der nato und des
warschauer paktes dazu kommt dritten ist
eine eindämmung strategie wobei die
seiten beiden machtblöcke versuchten den
einfluss des anderen einzudämmen und wen
geht zurück zu drängen aus regionen die
für sie von besonderer bedeutung machen
eine beinahe logische folge dieser
konkurrenz zwischen den beiden
machtblöcke 94 stellvertreterkriege sie
wurden in anderen ländern ausgetragen
die großmächte standen im hintergrund
und unterstützen die lokalen
konkurrenten
sie reichten von asien vietnam korea
über afrika angola mosambik bis latein
erika ein fünftes merkmal war ein
unglaubliches wettrüsten und ein
gleichgewicht des schreckens
das heißt dass beide seiten so viele
atomraketen hatten bis zu 70.000 um sich
gegenseitig mehrfach vernichten zu
können selbst wenn man als erste
angegriffen wird ab 1968 hat man hier
gegenseitige kontrollen eingeführt und
ab 19 80 hat man auch die streitkräfte
und die waffensysteme reduziert
voraussetzung dafür war ein mindestmaß
an gegenseitigem vertrauen jenes
vertrauen dass heute fehlt wie stellt
sich die situation heute dar
wir haben kein bipolare system sondern
multipolare system mit china und indien
sind zwei wichtige akteure dazu gekommen
das ermöglicht mehr kooperation
es fördert aber auch mehr spannenden und
mehr konkurrenz
wir haben auch keinen großen
ideologischen wettstreit mehr
es gibt zwar auf der einen seite das
liberale system der usa und des westens
und ein autoritäres system mit china und
mit russland aber die ideologie sind den
hintergrund getreten es geht heute viel
mehr um geopolitische interessen und
ökonomische interessen
es geht um macht und märkte und damit
verbindet sich auch schon drittens eine
eindämmung strategie die wir heute sehr
wohl beobachten können so ist zum
beispiel das vorgehen russlands in
georgien aber auch in der ukraine als
eindämmung zu interpretieren weil es
darum gegangen ist sie eine ausdehnung
der eu und der nato in diese region zu
verhindern und möglicherweise sehen wir
auch im südchinesischen raum bereits
eine eindämmung strategie von seiten
chinas wo es darum geht den einfluss der
usa zurückzudrängen und ist auch das
vierte merkmalen stellvertreterkriege zu
finden
der krieg in syrien ist mittlerweile ein
doppelter stellvertreterkrieg auf
regionaler ebene zwischen iran und saudi
arabien und auf globaler ebene zwischen
russland und den usa auch in der ukraine
sind diese merkmale vorhanden
in dem russland den separatisten ganz
massiv unterstützung gibt und die usa
kiew den rücken stärken
im südchinesischen meer sind alle
zutaten für einen stellvertreterkrieg
vorhanden es gibt aber noch keine
ausprägungen und wie sie das fünfte sind
bereich rüstung und atomare ab
wirkung aus die rüstungsausgaben sind
zwar in den letzten 20 jahren um 70
prozent gestiegen wir sind aber deutlich
entfernt würden den spitzenwerten des
kalten krieges große veränderung
hingegen im atomaren bereich statt
70.000 sprengköpfen 15.000 sprengköpfe
heute allerdings mit deutlich höherer
sprengkraft nicht nur fünf atommächte
sondern ein wie indien pakistan israel
und zuletzt nordkorea sind für weitere
dazugekommen
und wir haben einen trend zur
entwicklung von kleineren taktischen
nuklearwaffen möglicherweise haben die
eine größere abschreckungswirkung
allerdings könnte man auch versucht
seien sie leichte einzusetzen die
unberechenbarkeit ist daher gestiegen
wir haben heute im atomaren bereich ein
gleichgewicht des schreckens und den
faktor die unberechenbarkeit befinden
wir uns daher bereits wieder im kalten
krieg
zweifelsohne sind die wesentlichen
merkmale sieht man von der ideologischen
konkurrenz einmal ab heute zu
identifizieren allerdings in späterer
ausprägung
wir haben auch steigende
rüstungsausgaben wo man sich fragen muss
wohin führt das dient das nur der
modernisierung der streitkräfte
oder ist es doch die vorbereitung auch
für größere militärische
auseinandersetzungen
wir haben auch mehr akteure und mehr
spannungsfelder und wir haben eine
rhetorik und verhalten die fatale an den
kalten krieg erinnern
es ist er ja nicht übertrieben zu sagen
dass wir uns in der vorhalle zum kalten
krieg befinden
[Musik]